so we've got this Brewing competition  now between Mr Trump and Governor  DeSantis which has been you know obvious  in the last couple of days big if it's a  big big night for DeSantis and his  running mates in Florida uh that would  sharpen that competition a bit if Mr  Trump something to think about  yes it would and it's we're going to  focus on 2022.  you're right but that that is that's a  story to watch there's no doubt about a  long time we've got a twinkle in his  journalist died right there hey Sean  Hannity here hey click here to subscribe  to Fox News YouTube page and catch our  hottest interviews and most compelling  analysis you will not get it anywhere  else